[music]
now it will be 30 each, so I beat the documents less,
I saw that, apart from
you, the hero climbed, I drove to give dad
from the toilet came out here, I really have a balcony to
see the first shot of dad there,
such moments and
higher to the corridor are embroidered and we 3
sat all night after that we write it out
the street was sitting
[applause]
calculation again three times three times the same
fill it less often more let's say and
in general how to be there teaches my
daughter talking to the telly in
Poland and
immediately three blows in one fell
swoop I ran out all slept I think the feats
did not
run to the toilet  they run to
or the toilet I’m in waves, or we’ll
throw it all in the blood well 2 I’m not
able to eat
everything punched me into the toilet while I
go back and forth from the toilet in a
state of shock all in the kings
right there in incomplete then you are bricks
to the ceiling all 3 floors
she didn’t even find cats under the rubble
[music]
got hooked on the
need perhaps hello from russia
we are doing the explosion happened maybe not even
in the corridor then during  I was the second for him,
he just ran
across the glass,
then you will forget it in the basement 3 for Kulikovsky